es ist ein Fall von neue Brutalität der
mich wütend macht eben nach diesem Mord
an Luise ein Fall von gezeigt da Mobbing
unter Kindern dazu fünf Minuten sieht
man in einem Video dass wir hier nicht
zeigen
fünf Mädchen im Alter zwischen 13 und 16
Jahren wie Sie eine andere 13-jährige
eben quälen sie schlagen wir ins Gesicht
sie zwingen sie die Augen dabei zu
schließen am Ende drückt eine hier das
zeigt das Video nicht eine brennende
Zigarette ins Gesicht die Peine dauert
Minuten lang und erst nach langer Zeit
gelingt es dem Mädchen sich daraus zu
befreien weil ein Passant aufmerksam
wird auf sie und das Mädchen rettet die
Mutter erstattet Anzeige sie will dass
die Täterin bestraft werden dass ihre
Tochter gesündert wird ich glaube darauf
kann sie lange warten deshalb bin ich
dafür dass Jugendstrafrecht zu
verschärfen und aus diesem Grunde müssen
sie verantwortlich sein und für das
gerade stehen was sie da immer mehr
offenkundig an Gräueltaten begehen